بعد ان قطع الرئيس الامريكي زيارته
الاسيويه مسارعا ليستانف محادثات رفع سقف
الدين مع رئيس مجلس النواب كاظم بدل مشهد
مشهوبا بالتفاؤل الحذر رغم عدم التوصل
لاتفاق بعد بين الطرفين
متفائلون بامكانيه احداث تقدم لاننا
متفقان على ان العجز عن سداد الديون ليس
مطروحا سنتوصل الى شيء ما والاخفاق سيؤثر
حقا على صحه المواطن الامريكي الاقتصاديه
بل العالم كله ايضا
لم نتوصل الى اتفاق ولكنني شعرت بان
نقاشنا كان مثمرا في المجالات التي لنا
فيها اختلاف في الراي سيعاود طاقمنا
الاجتماع والانكباب على الامور التي
تحدثنا فيها
هذا في حين اصدرت وزيره الخزانه جانتيال
تحذيرا هو الاشد اقل من عشره ايام تفصل
الولايات المتحده عن سيناريو كارثي يقود
مكانتها الاقتراضيه ومكانتها الدوليه
ويضعف امنها القومي ان لم يتم التوصل
الاتفاق الجمهوريون يدفعون بتخفيض العجز
في الموازنه بتقليل الانفاق الحكومي خصوصا
في برامج الدعم الاجتماعي مقابل رفع سقف
الدين اما البيت الابيض يدفع بتخفيض
الانفاق الدفاعي وبرفع الضرائب كما يخضع
الرئيس بايدن لضغط ديمقراطي باستخدام
التعديل الرابع عشر من الدستور وعدم
التنازل لما يرون انه مناوره جمهوريه تتخذ
من مستقبل الاقتصاد الامريكي والعالمي
رهينه مقابل مكاسب سياسيه
الاحتمالات الثلاثه قد التواصل الى اتفاق
وسيصب ذلك في صالح الجمهوريين الذين
سيحصدون مكاسب في السياسات او عدم ابرام
تفاهم وسيكون ذلك استهطارا يحسب على
الجمهوريين وبيض ايضا والاحتمال الثالث
استخدام بيض احد خياراته القانونيه لمنع
الولايات المتحده من الاخفاق في سداد
الديون من بعيده تبدو ازمه سداد الدين
داخليه بتداعيات مؤلمه على المواطن
الامريكي لكن التحذيرات بهروله الاقتصاد
الامريكي نحو الهاويه ان لم تحل سيتردد
صداه حول العالم مع توقعات بانهيار اسواق
المالي بنسبه 45% وانخفاض قيمه الدولار
ودخول الولايات المتحده حاله ركود شديده
واشنطن